if we often ask ourselves okay Who am I
what's my true self what am i gifted at
what am i bad at oftentimes we'll answer
that assuming this one authentic self so
I'm just the sort of person who gets
angry at little things but I'm also the
sort of person who's very good at
tackling big problems so that's me and
then we'll think through okay what's a
good career for me what are good
relationships for me based on who I am
now getting suppose that's all wrong
suppose those are all simply patterns
we've fallen into so it may be
empirically right to say right now on
someone who gets angry at little things
and good at thinking big but that's just
because I fall into these patterns that
doesn't mean that's essentially me
that's just who I've become now if
that's right the question you should be
composing to yourself is not Who am I
the question you should post yourself is
what are these patterns I'm falling into
why do I get angry of these little
things all the time
why do I seem to be what I think is at
my best when I'm tackling big problems
and you begin to look at those little
things you do on a daily basis that are
sort of defining how're we responding to
the world why these little things make
us angry and you begin to alter those
why for something we think is good
thinking big tackling big problems well
what is it that I think I'm good at
there and what am I doing that I think
draws me out of my more negative sides
my angers and resentments and getting
angry little things what is about that
that I do well and can I do more of that
and other aspects of my life and you're
constantly trying to get a sense of what
are these patterns I've fallen into and
I don't want alter them some of them may
be good and you may want to develop them
in this example that thinking big some
of them may be really bad and are
probably sort of the tip of an iceberg
of something else going on that we spend
so much of our lives and anger and
resentment and jealousy that's not you
that's a pattern and it's all triple
the question they would always say is
what are these patterns how do I shift
them how do I break out of them and how
do I develop better ways of interacting
my homie if you take these ideas
seriously and I I do I think they're
really onto something
addiction is sort of the most extreme
example of something we're all falling
into so all of us are patterned
creatures that just repeat these
patterns endlessly and addiction is
simply an extreme form of this what this
means therefore is in dealing with
addictions as in dealing with any of the
patterns we're involved in as human
beings it's a very comparable concern
it's how do I break those patterns so
with the extreme one of addiction what
is it that's driving this endless
repetition just over and over and over
again
and oftentimes you begin with the breaks
at the little things the little things
that you can deal with oftentimes it can
be the little fears and anxieties to
begin to creep in I'm sort of in the
middle of the night when wakes up and
then in the morning again one wakes up
and it brings back those fears and just
sort of those begin escalating over the
course of the day leading one to return
to the object of one's addiction so
that's the place to start then
so why there's little fear setting in
why those anxieties are there little
things you can begin to do to break out
of those fears and anxieties and if you
begin with those little things those the
ones that over time begin to escalate
and shift your larger scale patterns now
that's not to say you also don't need
someone there saying don't do axiom
don't drink don't do drugs if you're an
addict but the reason that can be so
ineffective in the long run is you're
not really breaking your pattern you're
sort of breaking that you're trying to
break it at too late a stage like going
through the day with all the anxieties
now I'll try to not get that drink
well good but you've got to start
earlier you've got to begin with why
those little anxieties begin to gnaw at
you at 3:00 a.m. when you wake up why
when the alarm goes off they gnaw at you
all the more that's where you begin to
make the little breaks and over time
that's how you break these larger
patterns